I remember my teacher Julian that I talk
so much about uh the old hippie guru
chick yeah well her place is being
painted so I just offered that
guesthouse just for the next few days
Hawaii by Sedona by Audrey I'll get some
fun shots maybe ingredients song oh come
on you guys are going to white no that's
awesome man the kids and mother-in-law
are all going and I am here by myself
I'm Jillian some of my friends call me
Jilly but you can call me whatever you
want this is the biggest week in my life
I don't need to be playing host to some
whacked-out yogi chick she's just gonna
do a little yoga in the backyard and
then you won't even know she's here what
was that okay that was a girl okay I
won't say anything Doric I won't think
the thing you don't want me to think
even though I think that thing is way
cooler
why aren't you in Hawaii with the family
right now man this week to finish all of
this and it is stressing out I have a
command of the mind body and spirit any
minute
I mean you don't meditate with Jennifer
holy Shiva your musics contagious
inspiring this is gonna be good for you
is it really good for you bring home the
bacon let go we just came from your
house we're gonna go to the yoga party
are you Roger here his most critical
muscles need to be released oh oh yeah I
got some muscles that could be released
last night so the best music today I
think you really unblocked something
maybe you are a little guru
the doctor told me I did not figure out
how to relax
or exactly
root chakra is located between the anus
and the